LET'S MOVE ON TO PLAY TWEETS
THROUGH TIME.
SINCE TWITTER WASN'T AROUND IN
THE EARLY 1900'S, WE'LL NEVER
KNOW WHAT OUR TOOTHLESS
TYPHUS-RIDDLED ANCESTORS WOULD
HAVE TWEETED ABOUT.
I'M GUESSING MOSTLY BEAR
ATTACKS AND QUESTIONABLE
STATEMENTS ABOUT HARD WORKING
CHINESE.
THAT'S WHAT THEY WOULD HAVE
SAID.
I WANT TO MAKE IT VERY CLEAR.
>> AND WHAT I'M ABOUT TO SAY.
>> NO, NO.
SO, COMEDIANS, I'M GOING TO GIVE
YOU AN HISTORICAL EVENT FROM THE
EARLY 20TH CENTURY.
FOR 250 POINTS YOU HAVE TO TELL
ME WHAT KIND OF [BLEEP] REMARKS
YOU MIGHT HAVE TWEETED ABOUT IT.
PRESIDENT WILLIAM MCKINLEY IS
ASSASSINATED BY AN
POLISH-AMERICAN ANARCHIST IN
BUFFALO.
>>OMG MCKINZ NOOOO. I AM LEGIT
SOBBING INTO MY BONNET RN.
>> NEXT UP, TEDDY ROOSEVELT IS
THE FIRST PRESIDENT TO RIDE IN
A CAR.
>> GO BACK TO KENYA WHERE YOU
WERE ON A SAFARI ONCE.
[APPLAUSE]
#NOBAMA.
>> PRESIDENTS RIDING IN OPEN
CARS IS ALWAYS A GOOD IDEA.
[LAUGHTER]
>> NEXT UP.
THE WRIGHT BROTHERS
ACHIEVE FLIGHT. JASON.
>>WHILE YOU GUYS WERE DICKING
AROUND IN NORTH CAROLINA,
MY [BLEEP]ING BICYCLE'S BEEN IN
YOUR SHOP FOR THREE MONTHS
#WRONGBROTHERS.
[LAUGHTER]
WELL DONE.
MICHAEL.
>> CAN'T WAIT TO JOIN THE 10
FOOT CLUB.
[LAUGHTER]
>> YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
FINISH IN 12 SECONDS.
>> NO PROBLEM.
[LAUGHTER]
>> RIKI.
>> COOL BUT HOW IS THE MEASLES
VACCINE COMING?
#PRIORITIES.
>> WELL DONE.
WILLIAM HOWARD TAFT IS ELECTED
AND BECOMES OUR FATTEST
PRESIDENT. RIKI.
>>IN A HUNDRED YEARS
WE CAN REUSE THIS JOKE FOR
CHRIS CHRISTIE OR AN ACTRESS
THAT GAINS FIVE POUNDS.
>> MICHAEL IAN BLACK
>> TO QUOTE XTINA.
YOU'RE BEAUTIFUL NO MATTER WHAT
THEY SAY.
#NOBAMA.